Tammi is on the line in Austin Texas hi
Tammy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you my heart is beating as fast as
it can go
thank you for taking my call I wanted to
ask you a question on I have I just need
a little bit of prayer and encouragement
I wanted to find out if I said maybe
kept a little bit bigger of an emergency
fund
I had my emergency fund in place and the
last 12 and a half weeks I'm
self-employed my businesses pretty much
kind of you know a lot less and so and
then my car broke down
three times I own a little day brandy
card what I call it and it's $3,000 I
paid cash for it but now I'm kind of
just really almost going back to living
paycheck to paycheck however I paid off
54321 to get divorced and eight years
ago I struggled and stayed in the
trenches and I got divorced this year
well about 18 months ago and so I heard
that last 18 months I've just been
totally doing tell them look tell them a
Total Money Makeover and in 18 months
have been able to pay off fifty four
thousand dreams if you dollars out of
the seventy eight thousand so I'm not
the point right now we're in the spring
I'll pick my business will pick back up
again and things are going to look great
but the next three months are going to
be really difficult and we're like
barely doing any Christmas all my kids
I'm a single mom now and so it's just
it's just been real hard and I'm getting
ready in January to teach left to you
and I'm a little bit nervous about my
testimony is great but now I'm I'm now
just doing my emergency friends and I
feeling like maybe I'm not you know
where I should be I think you're think
you're doing I think you're doing a
whole lot better than you think you are
and by the way people that are
coordinators in Financial Peace
University we try to not allow perfect
people to do that we prefer people who
aren't perfect to do it so I hope you
still qualify yeah I gotta go yeah so on
because by the way the guy who wrote the
whole freaking thing did it because he
was a screw-up okay so um but you know
what what's happened is is that you came
out of the out of the gates
the divorce wide open and never even
slowed down correct and and you had a
lot of very incredible success right out
of the gate
congratulations was I started off making
on my own twenty six thousand dollars in
the year 2012 and I project to be about
a little of a hundred thousand dollars
and one year I can place my business
that much by just what are you doing I
work I only self-employed than I own on
some concession trailers I sell ice
cream on the ice cream lady in my can
and I went to your content of the ship
in june with chris hogan had an amazing
time and i I just kind of feel like why
would I get myself into this position to
not be as prepared I paid off so much
debt I wonder if I should've held back a
little bit you might should have if
you'd have known you were going to have
a slow December but why don't we get
really crazy creative for December why
don't you start calling around and find
a bunch of businesses that are having
Christmas parties and you set the
trailer up just outside the Christmas
party and at some point in the party
everybody gets free ice cream and you
come in and the company bought it for
them okay or something to tie into
Christmas rather than go oh it's not
summer and nobody's walking out there
that my ice cream trailer in the
sunshine because there's not any
sunshine and we're so we're out of
business until the Sun comes back out of
the spring let's did let's figure out a
way the say alright conventions or
companies or you know if you know if you
pulled up in front of our office and had
an arrangement I hope somebody doesn't
do this just because I said it but I
mean I would imagine if you called our
HR guys and said hey we're running a
Christmas special for ice cream we'd
like to pull up and give everybody in
your office an ice cream cone and we'll
give you a great bargain to do that but
you could all of a sudden get some
business and it'd be kind of bulk
business wouldn't it yes I do about 49
events a year and then I also have a
brick and mortar building I'm just
talking about something that's
off-season weird okay I'm just trying to
I'm trying to dream with you from a
marketing or a business model
perspective a little bit and say let's
just do something off-season weird
because you've got all of this talent
and know-how and equipment how can we
put it to work in a weird season because
most people don't think ice cream
Christmas goes together and so how can
we do that and and you know what's going
on and where's there but obviously if
there's any concerts or anything going
on which Austin's a pretty good music
town so are the least that's the rumor
that's a really good anything anything
like that to get because I think you
could do that but I was going to tell
you before I heard what you're doing is
and I started just dreaming about it
with you for a second what I was going
to tell you is you probably need to get
a side job until the dadgum seasonality
gets by so you don't starve out yeah I
actually did that so I do it I I
actually have a part-time job at the
Texas school to guess yeah but I mean
that that's fine but I got a feeling if
you just kind of got a creative way to
insert ice cream into somebody's life in
a weird time it could be very fun now
let me ask you this is it is it some
kind of is the ice cream kind of
mainstream stuff or is it designer or
high-end or what it's actually its own
homemade ice cream and it's about an
hour from Austin I was in a small little
town outside of Austin and to get into
Alton it's about three thousand dollars
to set up your trailer anywhere so I
have to of course date but it is I
understand
they charge a permit for you to set it
up anywhere well they charge it for the
events because they have a like a lot of
like they have like a Christmas tree
event at this park and stuff like that
okay but to get involved in someone's
event you'd have to buy in right right
but if I did something like you said in
call it a couple of places in ended HR
you still have to do a permit fee but I
totally can do that I know exactly what
you talked about I'm right on that yeah
just something to use what you've got it
and it's just it's just kind of what I
call weird hustle almost you know it's
not normal hustle normal hustles you
just do more what you've been doing and
you do it harder faster but more passion
this is like we got to do some kind of
unusual twist to get some money coming
in and that way you don't get off the
thing but here's the thing what here's
what you need to hear more than this
whole thing is this sidebar that's all
to the side right in the middle of it is
this Tami you've done awesome you've
done awesome and if you don't do
anything for the next 60 days but tread
water and feed your family you don't
make any more progress until the season
kicks back in you're fine okay you still
did awesome thank you
26,000 to a hundred thousand you
$54,000 in 18 months you are what's
known as a rock star thank you okay so
you're gonna be fine kiddo that's the
big deal right there is you just got to
remember you're kicking butt and but
then boom that thing dried up all of a
sudden and don't let Christmas catch you
off-guard from a business model next
year so I think you're on track though I
mean I think you're doing well I'm proud
of you a lot of people go through
heartbreaking stuff and marriages and
divorces and all this stuff and man it's
just and it takes two three four years
to get moving again it took you about 20
minutes was almost as if someone set you
free yeah that's pretty dadgum cool so
thank you for the call I just gotta tell
you you make $100,000 selling ice cream
out of a truck this is the greatest
country the world has ever known
okay so have a trailer this is just
awesome I don't understand why anybody
can't go figure out a way to do
something I wouldn't have thought of
that that's impressive
this is the Dave Ramsey show